with this footage people would turn to
your channel for the story
we have to watch these movies again
because we think we've missed something
big
making a movie is hard work no doubt
about it but
one rule that all filmmakers must follow
is to not reveal themselves or their
equipment on camera
sometimes though we see them anyway
let's look at some popular films and
find the moments where crew members and
equipment can be seen on screen
scared harry the harry potter series is
all about magic and through the magic of
movie making
we watched daniel radcliffe fly through
the sky on his broomstick
but it looks like some of that movie
magic can be seen
look closely you can see the seat of
harry's broomstick
you gotta give me some answers yes no
we're all about the romance between
bella and edward in the twilight saga
and while we're completely immersed in
the atmosphere the filmmakers created
there are a few times we're reminded
that we're watching a movie
let's watch the scene where bella gets
out of her truck take a look at the
windshield
you can see the boom mic wait
they said 50 years old the mandalorian
has captured our hearts with the
introduction of adorable little grogu
better known as baby yoda yeah yeah he
said yeah
while the show is a cinematic
masterpiece and a great addition to the
star wars franchise
there's a little mistake we caught in
one of the scenes
there's a man wearing jeans it's hard to
see
so you might miss it however if you
watch it back now though you won't see
him
disney took him out once the fans
noticed him first
you must look beyond this next one is
easy to miss
so keep your eyes peeled in harry potter
and the prisoner of azkaban
hermione and harry go back in time to
save sirius black and buckbeak
in one scene they dive behind a pumpkin
patch to avoid getting caught
but what we caught in that scene are the
outlines of battery packs and
microphones on the actors
jack sparrow isn't it captain jack
sparrow if you please
in pirates of the caribbean the curse of
the black pearl captain jack sparrow
says
bring me that horizon right before he
says that though
you can clearly see a crew member in the
background with his hat and sunglasses
he doesn't fit in with the rest of the
cast at all
in a way they exchanged one life of
adventure for another
spy kids is one of our all-time favorite
childhood classics
one of the coolest parts of that movie
were the awesome spy gadgets the
characters had
in one scene ingrid uses her super cool
spy mirror
it's quick but one shot includes a crew
member caught in the mirror's reflection
ingrid is supposed to be a secret spy
but it looks like the cameraman might be
capturing all of her secrets
do you wanna hear something a little
more interesting in harry potter and the
order of the phoenix
harry teaches other wizards and witches
the expecto patronum spell
in one shot you can see the cameramen
and other crew members in a reflection
behind ginny and her fellow witches
what are they doing there we highly
doubt they're part of dumbledore's army
i willy wonka will conduct you around
the factory myself
showing you everything there is to see
charlie in the chocolate factory
another one of our childhood favorites
near the end of the movie
charlie shines willy wonka's shoes see
those cool goggles wonka is wearing
in the reflection you can see crew and
equipment in the lenses
guess we'll have to be giving this movie
another watch
i'm gonna need a cup of coffee the dark
knight is one of the most iconic batman
movies of all time
but it's not immune to the occasional
slip-up
the atmosphere is so tense in this movie
we almost didn't notice
in the scene where batman questions the
joker we can see the cameraman and his
equipment for a very quick second
keep your eyes sharp for this one it's
there's something wrong with him if you
thought we were finished with harry
potter
guess again we've still got one more
harry potter mistake to show you
in the second part of the deathly
hallows the trio escapes gringotts and
washes up on shore
but watch the scene carefully see that
camera wobble
it lets us know that the camera and
consequently the crew is there filming
i am iron man no one will ever forget
iron man the movie that practically
launched the mcu
while in the main movie we couldn't find
any crew member or equipment slip-ups
we did find one in the post-credits
scene if you look at the pictures on the
wall
you can see the reflection of crew
members the story is the emp chief every
electronic device on the east coast goes
dark
in superman returns we have another case
of car window reflection
in this scene lois is investigating a
blackout that plagued her city
she has cleverly traced back the source
and drives up to the location
but when she gets out of the car the
camera crew and their equipment can be
seen in the car's reflection
we are what we believe we are
split definitely shook us to our core
while the movie is terrifying there is a
moment where we can see the crew when we
aren't meant to at the beginning of the
movie
when james mcavoy's character approaches
the car you can see crew members for a
split second in the car's bumper
god is a mean kid sitting on an anthill
with a magnifying glass and i'm the ant
we love bruce almighty especially when
we think about how
funny the movie is one of the funniest
parts of the movie is sam bruce's dog
one scene showcases much to bruce's
distress
sam peeing on a chair we caught
someone's hand
perhaps an animal trainer directing sam
you are all grounded what's grounded
in cheaper by the dozen we see steve
martin's character tom
and steven anthony lawrence's character
dylan hanging from the chandelier
but that's not all we see we also catch
a glimpse of a boom mic in the
background
what's it doing all the way down there
we can't help but wonder how filmmakers
miss this one
park the car and get your camera jake
gyllenhaal
stars in this neo-noir psychological
thriller and we
love it we also love re-watching it to
find that there was a crew member caught
on screen
when jake's character lou walks up to
the house after the van drives off a
cliff
you can see a crew member by the side of
the house oops
i'll show you how come on jack we all
swooned over jack and rose's romance in
james cameron's titanic
they certainly got our hearts racing
especially during the scene where they
have to escape rose's fiance
cal they make their escape by charging
into a waterlogged room
but wait a second what's that it's a set
light
that's not supposed to be there good
thing they fixed it for the blu-ray
edition
the fact that i'm not instagramming this
right now is insane
in jumanji welcome to the jungle we get
engulfed in
well a jungle alongside the main
characters
in the scene where the main characters
are running from the bikers
we see someone hiding in the trees it's
a cameraman
did he get trapped in the video game too
are you not entertained this is not why
you were here
gladiator is an epic film but we were
able to find some on-screen
equipment during the scene that takes
place in the coliseum in the famous
battle of carthage
one of the chariots turns over exposing
some equipment
it's a gas tank this one is one of the
more obvious slip-ups
maybe the filmmakers hoped no one would
notice but we did
did you you stay away i stay away
everybody stays happy in the fast and
the furious there is a scene where mia
changes her clothes upon spotting brian
when she takes off her shirt she throws
it at the camera it's a great transition
to the next shot but let's take a closer
look
before we cut away from the shot we see
a cameraman's elbow reflected in the
mirror
it's easy to miss so be careful to watch
out for it
you're the last person in the world i
expected to show up
we can't believe we missed these little
slip ups the first time we watched these
movies
but that's why it's always great to go
back and watch them again
while the filmmakers didn't intend to
have themselves in the movies
it's always fun to catch them in their
work
which one surprised you the most be sure
to let us know down in the comments
thanks so much for watching
you